[Musik]
Hallo. Herzlich willkommen zu Sallys Welt.
Eigentlich gibt es ja schon fast gar kein Rhabarber-Rezept,
was ich nicht schon auf meinem Kanal habe:
Rhabarber Crumble, Rhabarber Baiser-Kuchen,
Rhabarberkuchen mit Streuseln, Rhabarberkuchen mit Vanille,
Rhabarberknoten, Rhabarber-Limonade, Rhabarberkuchen vom Blech...
Im Prinzip habe ich schon fast alle durch,
aber ich habe jetzt noch ein Rezept für euch [Lacht]
- ich weiß, dass ein bisschen darüber gelacht wird –
JOSH: Rhabarber mit Nougat?
SALLY: Rhabarber Nougat fehlt noch. Oh!
Und Rhabarber Fanta-Schnitte. Ich dachte,
eigentlich hätte ich gern so ein leichtes Rhabarber-Rezept.
Deswegen fiel mir die Fanta-Schnitt ein.
Daher gibt es eine Abwandlung davon
– also ein luftiger Boden mit Rhabarber und einer Schmand-Sahnecreme.
Das machen wir heute! Dafür verwende ich 300 g geschälten Rhabarber,
2 TL Stärke, 3 Eier, 150 g Zucker, etwas Salz und Vanilleextrakt,
jeweils 100 g Sonnenblumenöl und Sahne,
200 g Mehl und 1,5 TL Backpulver.
Jetzt schält ihr den Rhabarber,
zieht also hier praktisch diese Fäden ab.
Es gibt ja verschiedene Sorten an Rhabarber.
Ich nehme jetzt den, der außen rot und innen grün ist
- ist auch so der gängigste, muss ich sagen.
Der wächst auch ganz gut; der wächst auch bei mir im Garten.
Der Rhabarber, der außen und innen rot ist,
ist ein bisschen seltener, aber milder.
Der ganz grüne ist richtig sauer,
aber den kann man auch ganz gut zu Kompott, Marmelade usw. verkochen.
[Musik]
Jetzt einfach in Stücke schneiden.
Hier kommt jetzt die Stärke dazu.
Die bindet nämlich dann das Wasser aus dem Rhabarber.
Kurz verrühren, dann kann ich das hier eben stehenlassen
und kann hier in meiner Rührschüssel die Eier mit dem Zucker,
Salz und Vanilleextrakt cremig rühren, so etwa 5-10 Minuten.
[Musik]
So sieht die Masse super aus.
Ich gebe jetzt die beiden Flüssigkeiten dazu, rühre sie kurz ein.
[Musik]
Dann kann ich das Backpulver mit dem Mehl dazu sieben
und auch ganz kurz unterrühren, aber wirklich nur kurz,
bis sich das Mehl schön vermischt hat.
[Musik]
Beim Mehl wirklich darauf achten: Immer nur kurz verrühren.
Außer beim Hefeteig – da ist es gut! Je länger, umso besser.
Aber bei Rührteigen und Biskuit das Mehl immer nur ganz kurz einrühren
oder sogar nur unterheben, damit der Kuchen nicht speckig,
also matschig wird.
Da habe ich hier meine Backform.
Ich nehme einen Tortenring, habe ihn auf 26 cm Durchmesser eingestellt
und da fülle ich jetzt die Masse hinein.
Wenn ihr wollt, könnt ihr auch statt der Sahne wirklich Fanta nehmen.
Dann ist es so richtig eine Fanta-Schnitte.
[Musik]
Ich habe es mir anders überlegt. Ich mache 24 cm.
Dann wird er schön hoch und luftig. Jetzt kurz verstreichen,
gern auch am Rand so ein bisschen hochstreichen.
[Musik]
Dann könnt ihr jetzt die Rhabarberstücke hier schön darauf verteilen.
Den Ofen habe ich bereits vorgeheizt, diesmal auf 160°C Heißluft.
Der Rhabarber ist noch relativ feucht.
Deswegen backe ich ihn bei Heißluft, dass der nicht zu nass ist.
Nach dem Backen direkt eine Stäbchenprobe durchführen
und dann abkühlen lassen.
[Musik und Uhr]
[Musik]
Jetzt hier noch eine Stäbchenprobe
– da klebt noch ein bisschen etwas dran. Also kurz weiterbacken.
[Musik und Uhr]
[Musik]
Jetzt ist der Rhabarberkuchen kalt und ich mache die Schmandcreme.
Ich habe mich jetzt für eine Schmand-Quarkcreme entschieden.
Ich verwende 250 g Sahnequark (den 40 %-igen), 200 g Schmand,
200 g Sahne, 80 g Puderzucker und San-apart.
Ihr nehmt jetzt einfach alles in eine Schüssel
- ein All-in-one-Rezept.
Quark, Schmand, Puderzucker und auch die Sahne.
Ihr dürft hier auch gern, wenn ihr wollt,
noch Vanilleextrakt dazu geben.
Ich habe es ja jetzt schon im Teig mit drin.
Deswegen lasse ich es jetzt in der Creme einmal weg.
[Aufschrei]
Eigentlich, eigentlich nein.
Ich glaube, ich gebe doch ein Schlückchen dazu.
Aber ihr könnt es auch einfach... 80 Flaschen! [Lacht]
Ihr könnt es auch einfach beim Teig belassen,
aber so ein bisschen Vanille in der Creme ist schon gut.
Jetzt wird alles verrührt mit San-apart steifgeschlagen.
Erst einmal rühren, bis sich alles verbunden hat. [Handrührgerät]
[Musik]
Ich nehme jetzt hier einen Spritzbeutel mit einer großen Lochtülle.
Ihr könnt die Creme entweder einfach darauf streichen
wie bei einer Fanta-Schnitte oder eben mit der Lochtülle arbeiten.
Da könnt ihr nämlich die Creme auftupfen.
Das ist jetzt hier ein Spritzbeutelständer
- ich fülle die Creme ein und kann sie dann schön reintupfen.
Danach stelle ich die Torte auch noch einmal kalt,
aber im Prinzip ist es wirklich eine relativ schnelle Torte,
die einfach aus 2 Komponenten besteht:
einem saftigen Rührteig und einer richtigen cremigen Creme. [Lacht]
Ich fange jetzt hier einfach außen an.
Beim Halten des Spritzbeutels einfach darauf achten:
Hinten immer festhalten und zudrehen. Die Hand vorne führt nur
und der Spritzbeutel wird schön senkrecht gehalten.
Also nicht so, weil dann fließt im Prinzip nur alles heraus,
sondern so.
[Musik]
Das ist das Tupfen-Gespür, dass man dann einfach weiß,
so groß müssen die Tupfen sein, damit es genau aufgeht.
Jetzt kommt die Torte abgedeckt in den Kühlschrank
und ich werde sie danach herauslösen
und ein bisschen mit Zimt bestreuen. Dann servieren.
Ich freue mich schon darauf.
Trotzdem bin ich gespannt.
Eigentlich bin ich ja so Rhabarber-Baiser-Fan.
Ich bin gespannt, ob die Torte das toppt
oder ob ich doch lieber Rhabarber-Baiser mag.
Wir werden es sehen. Wir werden es testen.
[Musik und Uhr]
Ich setze die Torten immer gern mit dem Ring auf die Platte,
denn da könnt ihr die Torte noch schön zentrieren
und dann den Ring ablösen.
Ohne Ring wird es schwierig, weil wenn man an der Torte drückt,
dann zerdatscht man sie.
[Musik]
Dann streue ich jetzt noch ein bisschen Zimt darauf.
Ich habe hier immer ein Schälchen mit Reis und Zimt,
denn der Reis bewirkt,
dass das Zimtpulver nicht in einem Schlag durch das Sieb durchgeht.
So kann man es ein bisschen besser dosieren.
[Musik]
Hier habe ich noch ein paar Mandelblättchen.
Die habe ich schon geröstet und abkühlen lassen.
Diese streue ich noch darauf.
Dann können wir die Torte gleich probieren.
Könnt ihr auch so ein bisschen zerdrücken. Dann sind sie kleiner.
[Musik]
Der Rhabarberkuchen ist fertig. Heute darf Sarah probieren.
SARAH: Sally, weißt du, was ich mir überlegt habe?
SALLY: Was?
SARAH: Wie wäre es, wenn du Barbara heißen würdest?
SALLY: Und ich backe einen Rhabarberkuchen!
Dann wäre ich die Rhabarber-Barbara.
SARAH: Wenn du eine Bar hättest,
dann wäre das die Rhabarber-Barbara-Bar.
SALLY: Stell dir vor, dann kommen ein paar Barbaren und wollen den
Rhabarberkuchen essen, so kleine Murats.
Dann sind es die Rhabarber-Barbara-Bar-Barbaren.
SARAH: Mit Bärten. [Sally stimmt zu]
Die haben lange Bärte. [Sally lacht]. Ich komme nicht weiter.
Rhabarbara... Rhabar... Babaren... Bärte.
Boah, ich habe es richtig!
SALLY: Ja, und die müssen dann zum Barbier. Dann wären es die:
Rhabarber-Barbara-Bar-...
BEIDE: Barbaren-Bärte-...
SALLY: Barbier. [Sarah verneint]
[Beide lachen]
Das hat überhaupt keinen Sinn ergeben.
[Alle lachen]
SALLY: Das wäre der: Rhabarber-Barbara-...
BEIDE: Bar-Barbaren-...
SALLY: Barbier, der die Bärte schneidet.
JUTTA: Barbier beim Friseur.
SALLY: Genau.
SARAH: Das weiß ich.
SALLY: Gott sei Dank, heiße ich nicht Barbara, sonst hätten wir jetzt
den ganzen Struggle mit Rhabarberbarbara Kuchen.
SARAH: Rhabarberbarbarabarbarbierbärte... Bärtebarbierbarbaren...
SALLY: Wir filmen gerade, aber egal. [Beide lachen]
Jutta crasht alles – egal!
SARAH: Sie nimmt uns nicht ernst,
wenn wir über Rhabarberbarbaras reden.
SALLY: Sie dachte sich so...
JUTTA: Ich habe mir schon gedacht, dass ihr...
SALLY: Jutta dachte sich so:
So einen Quatsch machen sie niemals vor der Kamera.
Jutta kennt uns noch nicht so lange.
Wir probieren jetzt den Rhabarberkuchen...
SARAH: ... von der Rhabarberbarbara.
Gibt’s den in der Rhabarberbarbarabar zu kaufen?
SALLY: Ich würde den in der Rhabarberbarbarabar anbieten.
Und die Rhabarberbarbarabar wäre dann gegenüber vom Barbarenbarbier.
SARAH: Und die Rhabarberbarbarabarbarbieren
würden das auch essen, oder?
SALLY: Das wären die Stammgäste! Der Barbier würde es auch essen.
[Beide lachen]
SARAH: Jetzt ist meine Zunge verknotet.
SALLY: Dann ist da ein Barbar oder ein Barbier,
der Stammkunde in dieser Rhabarberbarbarabar ist.
JOSH: Und der zahlt bar. [Sally wiederholt]
[Alle lachen]
SARAH: Das ist dann Rhabarberbarbarabarbarbarenbargeld.
SALLY: Wir probieren jetzt einfach.
SARAH: Zum Glück heißt du nicht Barbara.
SALLY: Gott sei Dank!
SARAH: Das wäre krass.
SALLY: Magst du Rhabarberkuchen? [Sarah verneint]
[Beide lachen]
SARAH: Doch! Mag ich! So nach 4 Stunden.
SALLY: Mit Baiser.
SARAH: Das ist doch kein Baiser. Das ist Schmand, oder? [Sally bejaht]
Hast du gerade Baiser gesagt?
SALLY: Ja, magst du mit Baiser oder...? Weil ich finde,
mit Schmand habe ich ihn noch nicht gesehen. [Sarah stimmt zu]
Nur mit Crumble, also Streuseln, oder mit Baiser,
aber so habe ich jetzt auch noch nicht [Sarah stimmt zu]
BEIDE: Mmh!
SARAH: Boah, der ist sehr lecker! Cremig. [Sally stimmt zu]
Ich habe ihn mit Baiser auch nicht... ach nein...
[Beide lachen]
... mit Schmand jetzt auch noch nie gegessen.
SALLY: Ist gut, gell?
SARAH: Aber passt gut zusammen.
SALLY: Mmh! Und Zimt noch! [Sarah stimmt zu] Sehr erfrischend.
SARAH: Ich finde, der sieht ein bisschen weihnachtlich aus.
SALLY: Ja, ein bisschen – leider! Aber er ist sehr erfrischend.
Also ich finde schon, es ist ein Sommerkuchen.
SARAH: Voll! Ich finde... Ich weiß nicht, wie ich es ausdrücken soll.
Rhabarber sieht nicht so lecker und süß aus, wie er schmeckt.
SALLY: Ja, Rhabarber ist auch ein Gemüse.
SARAH: Wenn man Rhabarber sieht, denkt man immer an etwas Herzhaftes.
Im Kuchen kann ich mir‘s nicht so vorstellen, aber schmeckt immer gut.
SALLY: Ich muss auch sagen – Rhabarber ist ja ein Gemüse,
aber ich habe Rhabarber noch nie herzhaft zubereitet.
Also ich mag... du? [Sarah verneint]
Gell? Krass! Und die Erdbeere ist eigentlich...
BEIDE: Eine Nuss.
SALLY: ... ist ein Rosengewächs
und diese kleinen Nüsschen darauf sind die Nüsse,
und der Kürbis ist die größte Beere der Welt.
SARAH: Das wissen nur Klugsch***er.
[Alle lachen]
SALLY: Ja, so viel dazu!
SARAH: Ich glaube, damit kannst du auf einer Party punkten.
SALLY: Ja, oder?
Ich kann auf einer Party mit so einem Kuchen beeindrucken.
SARAH: Ich singe einfach. [Sally stimmt zu]
Du bringst Kuchen, ich singe.
SALLY: Okay. Gibt es einen Barbara-Song? Barbara Streisand.
SARAH: [Stimmt an] Kennst du doch, oder?
SALLY: „Barbara Streisand“ – dü dü dü düü dü dü...
SARAH: Warte, ich mache Beatboxing. [Beide lachen]
[Beatbox-Töne]
[Beide lachen]
Kannst du mal singen?
BEIDE: [Beatbox-Töne] dü dü dü düü dü dü... Barbara Streisand.
dü dü dü düü...
SALLY: Barbara hat uns den Rest gegeben.
Also der Kuchen ist sehr, sehr lecker.
Ich kann mich ehrlich gesagt nicht entscheiden,
ob ich den oder den mit Baiser besser finde.
Beide! Man muss sich nicht entscheiden.
SARAH: Wann gab es den mit Baiser?
SALLY: Morgen!
SARAH: Dann kann ich mich noch nicht äußern.
Aber morgen weiß ich es dann.
SALLY: Okay.
Rezept gibt es wie immer in der App.
SARAH: Und auf dem Blog.
SALLY: Tschüss!
SARAH: Aktiviert die Glocke.
[Alle lachen]
SALLY: Und bitte schreibt mehr Rhabarberwitze drunter.
SARAH: Ich muss weinen.
SALLY: Ich suche jetzt eine Barbara und gebe ihr den Rhabarberkuchen.
Und dann soll sie eine Bar eröffnen – die Rhabarberbarbarabar.
[Musik]